let's talk about a good person because I
watched this last night and you did an
amazing job and you have you wrote this
yeah you uh directed it I don't want to
give away too much but it is a it is a
heavy movie in places uh in in but it
has to be I mean you're talking about uh
the the main character who's played by
Florence Pugh goes through this
incredible uh very intense situation
early in the film that uh that
reverberates throughout the rest of the
movie but I mean the cast Morgan Freeman
yeah I mean he's pretty extraordinary uh
I I just was
I how do you get Morgan Freeman to do
your movie well um I'll start with that
I had made a studio sort of heist film
uh it was a remake of going in style
with with him him Michael Keaton and
Alan Arkin and so we had a relationship
um but I I never thought he was even a
possibility because this was a little
tiny budget Indy and Morgan doesn't
usually do those
um
um so I wrote the movie for Florence
um we were in a relationship and I just
think she's the most incredible young
actress on the planet I was I I was and
am in awe of her and um
and and I was dealing with a lot of
grief
um
um so which I can talk about more if you
want but but I'll just circle back to
Morgan I wrote this piece it was about
it I wanted to mix uh the story of grief
with humor because I don't want anything
that's too modern I mean yes there's a
lot of drama in the film but there's a
lot of humor as well yes there is yeah
and um and so I it was real it became
real and I said I'm just gonna start
with i and there was a character of a
senior citizen who I wanted to be some
great acting Legend and I thought well
why don't I this is crazy he's never
gonna do it because we can't afford to
pay him the Morgan Freeman amount of
money
um but I do know him and I know he likes
me so let me try and um I remember
Florence we were in my My Den and my
phone rang and the times Morgan and I
have communicated it's never been over a
phone call it's always been a very Curt
text but my phone rang and she held it
up and it said Morgan Freeman wow and uh
I was like
and I picked it up and he said I see
myself on every page of the script oh
wow that's fantastic and that's when um
my life changed again and he said um he
goes I don't normally do uh this but
meaning attach myself to a movie that
wasn't even really fully set up yet um
but but I'm with you and then of course
we were we were on our way to being made
it's so crazy because I mean that's an
amazing story in and of itself but also
Morgan Freeman has the most next to like
James Earl Jones the most iconic voice
yeah uh and especially voice over voice
yeah he used to be my uh voicemail
message
um because he lost him
when we were when we were making going
in style uh he uh he lost a bet to me
and my prize was that he was my outgoing
voicemail what was the map what was the
message like hello this is Morgan
Freeman Zach can't come to the phone
Zach can't come to the phone he's with
Andy Dufresne
I guess I just miss my friend I miss my
friends
because hope is a thing that you have to
hang on to uh it'd be great if it just
kept going and going and going the
penguin must sit on the eggs
wait we're doing we're doing that now
he does have the most beautiful voice oh
my god well I mean he's fantastic and uh
I mean God Florence Pugh is incandescent
she's uh she's Next Level yeah and and
uh you and also there's Molly Shannon as
well Molly Shannon uh playing the mom is
is terrific and you know what I what
what I like is I'm drawn to stories
where
everybody's vulnerable and everybody's
flawed I think we all have our own stuff
and and not me I would accept you yeah
I'm gonna check with what we know of you
that's I think you have a skewed view
but I anyway all right I wanted to uh I
feel no one everyone has their flaws and
everyone is battling what they're
battling
um I wanted to make a movie about
um grief and standing back up from grief
um but not have it be so modern and and
depressing that you just don't want to
watch it so in order to do that I
thought of times in my life that have
been so dark but then someone and I'm
sure at least you because I know your
personality can agree that someone then
finally says something funny and you
have this release where you're like
that's God yes the experience of Joy or
laughter is much more powerful if the
pressure's built up yeah so uh when it's
finally released it it I think that's
the trick yeah so that's what I was
trying to do is because I felt that in
life at some of the darkest times in my
life someone says something funny and
you just all belly laugh because you
just you've got nowhere else to go but
up and
um and I wanted to sort of put that into
the film that just when when when shit's
getting real and people are are things
are really um Grim there's a there's a
comedic release is there uh you know
because I'm thinking
again I'm trying to put myself in in
your place which is impossible but if if
I say cut and then I have to go up and
give Morgan Freeman a note you know what
I mean I just it feels like it would be
you yes you are uh you are you have
earned the right you're a a proven
director and you've this you're the
writer director of this film and you've
you've earned the right but still it's
Morgan Freeman well you must flash back
too I remembered when I was working at
Chili's
with Morgan Freeman with Morgan Freeman
but it was his chilies he was the
manager
um it's funny you say that well first of
all Morgan really only would prefer to
do one take of every single thing oh wow
um but as a director that's hugely
impossible because you know there's
multiple Morgan Freeman is truly almost
always perfect but you know there's
there's a there's a background person
that crossed in the wrong spot or the
camera was out of focus so you often are
in the position as a filmmaker of saying
okay that was an awesome take one we're
gonna go again and then you would hear
why
oh my god
wow and then I'd be like Morgan you were
awesome
um we can do better with the camera and
also can we change those blinds and can
you not cross when when that you know
you're directing the movie like you
normally do yeah but but part of it is
like he's he's very um he teases like
that he's very um
he's like but that's his that's his Vibe
but I mean a little bit of it is like
let's keep moving but he knows I'm gonna
do more than one take and in terms of
directing thing I would say the best
analogy I can use with someone like him
or someone like Florence Pugh is you're
not
you're not teaching you're not teaching
or telling them how to act right you're
having a comment it's analogous to a
conductor who has a genius first
violinist I I can't play the violin like
that person can
but I can say I need to hear
the bassoon's a little more so if that
section can you quiet down do you know
what I mean yeah so I'm not going to him
and being like bro what are you doing
Morgan
Jesus Morgan
what the hell was that I'm going in and
engaging in a conversation going do you
think that maybe in this scene it should
be more X because later we're gonna do y
right and then he uh and then more often
than not he's like right that's good
let's do that let's do that so if I had
gone up to him and said hey Morgan it's
called acting that would have been
horrible let's give it a try
shall we that wouldn't have worked
she was directing career ever Governor
Brian was a movie director for it says
here
yeah but one take you wouldn't even you
didn't even you wouldn't even got in the
wow
oh no oh I know it would have happened
suddenly he's not there
some people are packing up equipment